so I've totally lost my voice as well
it's just I sound like Tom Waits I'm
gonna do this the whole time let's start
with you ortho tell us a little bit
about rip hunter and under what
circumstances we meet him I'm so I get
so paranoid with why I'm allowed and not
allowed to say so
he's from the future and from a future
that he's not particularly happy with
come back for various reasons to get
this ragtag team of knock cases together
to try and battle Vandal Savage who we
saw a little bit of in that flash teaser
and we all got very very excited we're
all just jumping around like kids about
there watching now among the group we
have our Ray Palmer know Brennan in the
arrow premiere we saw there's a whole
memorial sign at the town line for raid
there's a little bit disingenuous of him
to be alive yeah just stay dead well
maybe but hopefully he's welcome back if
he decides to to you know to show
himself again or maybe he's in terrible
peril and we'll find out soon
how is Ray these days is he ironed out
the kinks with the whole system and the
suit is he still backfiring and Springs
springing out or well well when we find
him in legends of tomorrow a lot of
stuff has been worked out prior to his
arrival or his resizing if you will I
guess you know that that that maybe
there's still some stuff needs to be
worked out and figure it out but when we
get into legends of tomorrow yeah most
of everything's figured out he's got a
little more confidence indeed Sierra
where do we pick up with Kendra is she
where she had in her evolution as a
superhero she has no idea what's going
on um we see her on the flash first and
she just moved to Central City
and she just is trying to figure out who
she is as a human and then she finds out
that she's a little bit more than that
and we meet Hawkman and I think he's
kind of helping her out with that with
remembering who she is and the powers
that she has so things are good between
the two of them so far well I wouldn't
say that it's a little jarring when you
meet someone for the first time and they
say that you're the reincarnated lover
from 4000 years ago so it's a
complicated relationship
fun OkCupid every now and then bill well
obviously we have a much larger team
than we have on the panel here give me
three words each to describe let's start
with Captain cold cold calculating
confident do if they have to all
alliterative psychopathological pyro
maniacal and fiercely loyal you're
totally cheating dr. Martin Stein
arrogant intelligent and curious about
the universe and we have a newcomer Jax
Jackson played by Franz drama we do Wow
got excited there he is skeptical angry
and not that excited about being part of
his team and of course white canary aka
Sara Lance
she's freshly dead she's gotta be again
she I would say is is is haunted lethal
and and searching for some sort of
connection I want to ask you to the
actors on the panel who does your
character get along with best and who do
they butt heads with the most start with
are evil and rip hunter I don't know who
he gets on with maybe no one but maybe
everyone that's my answer
and who's the biggest thorn in his side
sorry and who's the biggest thorn in his
side no it changes like everyone's
really irritating I don't think he's
quite thought his planned through like
he's got Riley need to get these people
together and we're gonna go save the
world it's gonna be great he thought it
was just gonna be one episode in 916
yeah and then when it turns out to be
more as I oh god I'm going to spend time
with these people so yeah I think
friendships form as they naturally do in
life but I think he's encouraging it I
think he wants to keep it fairly for
more Brienne and who does Reagan along
with best buds with well get along with
best is a little bit hard to say so far
I would say probably
canary and and and Hawkgirl just because
we haven't had that much interaction yet
and they're not as crazy as everyone
else well yeah give it time we're
learning all learning about each other
and let's say Leonard snart and and and
professor Stein a little bit are they
really kind of more than yeah I mean
there's a there's a bit of a rivalry
kind of aspect going on between the two
of the science guys and cr1 rivalry I
think my answer for both is Hawkman like
I said complicated so I think he annoys
a crap out of me but he also is we have
a connection that we can't really
explain so Phil what is this showing
look like on a weekly basis I know the
Big Bad is Vandal Savage but on a
week-to-week what are they gonna be
going up against well you know it's not
a traditionally episodic show you know
it's highly serialized and it's sort of
so far has broken down into chapters
where we'll go back to a specific time
and place so far it's all been sort of
20th century history as the backdrop but
the way we've imagined Vandal Savage is
he's an immortal shadowy figure who's
been sort of slyly winding his way
through history and never attracting the
sort of direct attention of
of the world of mortals but at the same
time sort of affecting events in the way
that you know he you know sort of we
always liken him to the devil in the
sympathy for the devil song where he was
he's been at all of those sort of you
know moments when history was sort of
hanging in the balance and so you know
week to week we're trying to intercept
him throughout the ages you know for the
purpose of saving the world but you know
half the time we're trying to correct
the the things that we've screwed up
along the way
so as the characters jump around in
timer they're gonna have to adopt the
clothes of the period like are we gonna
see white canary and go-go boots I'm
asking for a friend that's I a hundred
percent you will see her in go-go boots
that was like when I signed on to this I
was like there's gonna be go-go boots
yeah we we have like a what we call the
fabrication room on the ship so every
time people go out into the world it's
amazing you can get your your sort of
your wardrobe to match so yeah we'll see
the 70s
we'll see the 50s we'll see the Cold War
we'll see terrorism
maybe we'll see dinosaurs I don't know
well it's gonna say San Diego comic-con
uh one of the producers described the
show as bonkers yeah I think that was
conservative that was I think it's just
fully insane all right there you go
fully insane midseason on the CW we're
gonna take some audience questions now
we have microphones on both sides of the
room see if we can get in two or three
from each side oh well I believe these
lights have blondie I didn't reload
trust me so far okay thank you all for
coming for one you say sighs roud
totally overwhelming okay we're gonna
start over here on my right with this
one hi my name is charisma and Brandon
um with no offense to the memory of
Christopher Reeves and Henry Cavill
who's doing an excellent excellent job
right now you were by far my favorite
Superman thank you because you truly
embodied the geek side of Clark Kent and
we really appreciate that as comic geeks
here so just as I thought if you are
able to I would love to get a picture
with you this is my first con if not my
question
you is how different is it going from a
DC superhero like Superman to Adam who
is not as figured out not as together as
Superman was from day one well yes you
and only you when we're done I'll step
over here and we'll take a picture
congratulations on your first con there
are similarities and differences I think
one of the similarities between the two
is actually they're just trying to
figure things out I mean Superman was
always trying to figure out how to be
human through Clark so that was the
exciting thing that was what I lived
through in him his excitement about
being able to be human and that's
present in Ray Palmer as well as he's
just geeking out about life he loves
life and science and making people's
lives better so he just now has been
able to made that manifest into
physically being able to help save
people's lives in a different way and
Superman obviously does that all the
time did I answer the question yes
switching this side we have a question
from it looks like two-face yep so hi
I'm Jonah I miss you guys in San Diego
you were really cool so what I was
wondering was this show was a totally
original show with with the somewhat
original store with someone original
storyline with characters facing some
challenges that's something that we
haven't been seen
I was wondering really how was it to
play that and to write that well that's
a great question yeah you know I have to
say it's it's very exciting to write
that the you know the fact that we've
selected characters that that that their
backstories and personalities haven't
been as fully fleshed out as some of the
the sacred cow characters in the DC
Universe you know it means that we have
a huge amount of latitude in sort of
reimagining them and in in the same way
that I feel like the the that arrow and
flash were able to sort of dig under the
humanity of their characters and and the
fact that we're taking this crazy
collection of people that have never
breathed the same
err forget about having been forced to
be on a time-traveling spaceship
together it gives it like a really just
it feels very fresh and and it you know
the sort of character tensions in the
best possible way it's you know it's
pure chaos
I don't know how does it how do you guys
enjoy playing your characters I I'm so
excited for the possibilities I mean for
someone a character who's lived hundreds
of lifetimes now there were time
travelling I'm hoping that we meet some
other versions of Hawkgirl I think
that's such a cool possibility it's just
a unique opportunity to have done both
to a follow in the footsteps of a great
performance and then to also be able to
you know put my own polish on something
new and create you know kind of from the
ground up a character as well very cool
yeah it's this kind of a responsibility
to to pay homage to what's been before I
suppose and to we've been reading the
comics and you know but then you want to
grab that and take it somewhere
somewhere new that is exciting for
everyone yeah to witness and you know
for us as writers just knowing that we
had this cast in in place and such
indelible personalities it made it so
much easier to write the you know in
particular the pilot when you normally
write a pilot and you have a sort of
vague image in your mind of who each of
these people are gonna be but like I
knew you guys I we had actually been at
comic-con together before word of the
pilot was written and so like just
knowing you as human beings it just made
the sort of the writing so much more
rich that we could imagine who the
actual actors were going to be that what
that was it that was a thrill great
questions back to this side uh hi first
of all Arthur obvious you were fantastic
and Doctor Who yeah hello hi
and Brandon you had such a wonderful
little cameo sort of performance in
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world it was
absolutely thank you I just want to ask
I'm an actor and I was just curious why
did you guys choose become actors what
made you want to do acting Wow just just
always done it like growing up with it
with loving stories and my mom's a
puppeteer so I kind of grew up in a
weird house full of Papa's stories so
like ever had a bit of a weird backwards
upbringing and and then this was all I
can do so well yeah I knew right from
from an early age which is had no
revelation I was just like grew up going
yeah I'm going to be an actor I grew up
in a family was always entertaining my
parents were both musicians and I didn't
really think of it as a real possibility
going from in a small town in Iowa but
some Iowa some opportunities were
presented and doors opened and I you
know I was like okay well we'll see what
we'll see where this goes with the kind
of fearless attitude I guess and here we
are
Wow no one in my family performed at all
I'm a little bit of the weird black
sheep because they're like why do you
want to do this I was always a singer
first and I thought that that's kind of
what I wanted to do and then I did a
musical in high school and it kind of
changed my mind and I think I was really
excited by the aspect of like I get to
be someone completely different than
myself because I was like such a loser
in high school
I was like I get to be cool people on
stage yeah but now I think I do it
because I get to tell really amazing
stories and we get to meet like amazing
people who experience these stories with
us and hear how it affects you guys and
that's kind of why I do it now I like
telling stories and and hopefully
changing someone's life or for the
better thank you so much we have two
more minutes let's see if we can get
into more questions over here a quick
question flash and arrow have both
teased about Batman when is someone from
the bat family actually gonna show up in
your universe
yeah Phil no one's not gonna happen
I mean it's not like we're saying like
no we will not let Batman be on our show
beyond our control probably I would
imagine yeah those things get tricky
going back to this side shout-out to you
Brandon
thank you sir but good the gentleman has
on a Superman shirt yes so my question
is Superman awesome Adam even more
awesome if the two of them were to meet
what would be their first words to each
other don't I know you
hi my question is are there gonna be
surprising you or romantic relationships
on this show because I know some people
are shipping Rae and Sarah already oh
yeah that too well when people are on a
vessel of any sort like a ship you know
when you're at sea submarine submarine
anytime you're in a writers room any
time you're in close life-or-death
quarters you know weird things happen
between people and on a flying
time-traveling spaceship because it's
policy on the ship is it's pretty racy
especially when one of them is in goes
that was a yes let's do one last
question and then we are done take it
away thank you my name is Shawn this
questions for Arthur you're now playing
a British guy traveling through time
with a group of people trying to save
the world
yeah are you ready for all the
comparisons to the doctor and how are
they different they're very different
and like I've come into this knowing
that there's gonna be those comparisons
and it'd be foolish of me to go I don't
know what you're talking about
Takas obviously yeah exactly but it's a
very different challenge for me and he
is very different from the doctor I
don't know this the examples I can give
I totally lost my voice big
I spent the whole day fighting on Friday
and beating someone up which I don't
think would happen indoors
you know there are some similarities I'm
English and wear a long coat and can
travel through time and become heard of
time speak which is thanks for but apart
from that the similarities kind of end
there and I'm really excited for you to
see this kind of weird mysterious
adventurer